et lui vous êtes en tournée avec votre
spectacle
elie semoun se prend pour qui la fait et
vous serez du 22 septembre au 10 octobre
ou à l'olympia bien sûr bien sûr un
grand classique j'irai voilà vous aurait
pu faire tout le monde en parle
débutant un public voilà je t'annonce
que l'émission s'arrête alors c'est très
bonne santé monsieur de carolis
ce qui est extraordinaire dans votre
spectacle c'est votre capacité à
interpréter successivement des
personnages très différents les uns des
autres rapports à gérard qui ne s'est
joué qu'un rôle
on assiste et vous avez dit sérieusement
vous avez dit comme clara morgane il ya
plusieurs personnes en moi hein j'ai dit
ça c'est moche l'attitude que tu as
enfin bon c'est vrai que c'est le seul
point commun que je peux avoir avec elle
tout à fait autre chose qu elle oui mais
moi je fais l'amour avec deux mille
personnes tous les soirs elle je sais
pas c'est pas 2000 souffle était au cap
d'agde il ya un personnage que j'adore
c'est kevin à voile à faire il était
arrivé au kevin r